週刊金融日記
2026年8月31日 第七百四十六号
スケーリング則でエーアイの性能が順調に上がっても性能が上がりすぎるからこそ国家に規制されてダメになる論について
アンソロピック史上初２兆ドルアイピーオーへ
週末の丸の内でフレンチで居酒屋風に楽しみました
SKハイニックス株の買い方について
他
こんにちは。
ふじさわかずきです。
東京に着いたときは、いきなりゲリラ豪雨で、うんこが下水から溢れて東京湾に流れてきたり、夜中に緊急地震速報で叩き起こされたりして大変だったんですが、その後は、涼しくていいですね。
そして、無事に免許の更新が終わりました。
前回はコロナ禍で日本と香港の渡航が大変で、期限が切れたんだけど特例で更新できる、という感じだったんですが、今回は期限切れなんで、なんか講習は、違反とかした人たちといっしょのところでした。
僕は外見で人を判断するような人たちが大嫌いですし、僕は絶対に外見で人を判断しないんですが、その時は、金髪の人とかタトゥーの人とかいて、なんか見るからにアレだったんですよ。
しかし、今回は、ゴールドなんで、30分の簡単なやつで、見るからにちゃんとした身なりで顔つきまでまともそうな人たちばかりで、とても良かったですわ。
そろそろ、香港に戻ろうかと思います。
ランチが安くて美味しいので、２回食べました。
笑。
ジムのあとにコンビニでビールとおつまみがいいですわ。
Xサブスク、月３ドルなんですが、アップルやグーグルにピンハネされるスマホのXアプリからではなく、宇宙開発を応援するためにも、天才イーロン・マスクさんのXのウェブをブラウザで開いていただいて、そこから直接ポチっていただけると助かります。
神決算は当たり前で、事前の期待を大幅に超えないと毎回株価が下がっていたエヌビディアですが、今回は神決算予想の上を行き、さすがに株価が上昇しました。
決算分析レポートをアップしました。
あと、こんやあたりに、Broadcomのレポートもアップします。
「エーアイ革命の覇者 エヌビディア FY2027 Q2 決算」
こんしゅうも読者から興味深い投稿がいくつもあります。
見どころは以下のとおりです。
国家権力が国民全員に各分野の大学教授を超えるレベルのエーアイへのアクセスを許すとは思えず規制でエーアイじゅようが鈍化することを恐れています。
SKハイニックス株を買いたいのですがエーディーアール、米国預託証券で買うと為替や取引手数料がかかる上に30パーセントもプレミアムがついている件と所長がコスピを買った理由についてです。
『メモリ半導体株の低ペロウは歴史的なミスプライスなのか』の最終回を早く書いてほしい。
それではこんしゅうもよろしくお願いします。
１．スケーリング則でエーアイの性能が順調に上がっても性能が上がりすぎるからこそ国家に規制されてダメになる論について
せんしゅうは、計算資源をぶっ込めばぶっ込むほど、スケーリング則という公式で予測される通りに、エーアイの性能が上がり続け、それゆえに、ハイパースケーラーたちが最大限の資力でエーアイデータセンターを作り続け、オープンエーアイやアンソロピック、xAIなどのエーアイ企業も、計算資源の獲得に莫大な資金を何の躊躇もなく投入し続けている、ということを解説しました。
この人類史上圧倒的なきぼのキャップエックス競争は、勝者総取りを恐れて、より高い性能を引き出すために、赤字なのに各社が必死でぶっ込んでいる、というよくある見方とは正反対で、エーアイデータセンターはすでにめちゃくちゃ儲かっている、ということも解説しました。
エヌビディアのジェンセン・ファンの言葉を借りれば、ジーピーユーの投資回収期間は１年未満です。
さらに、エーアイかいはつの最前線にいるアンソロピックは300兆円以上という史上最高額でのアイピーオーが噂されています。
エーアイはすでにボロい儲けが出ています。
「アンソロピック、史上初の320兆円アイピーオー らいげつにも 法人需要狙い収益性高く」
「エーアイ革命の覇者 エヌビディア FY2027 Q2 決算」
『週刊金融日記 第七百三十八号 エーアイ企業はトークン製造工場を建設してトークンを世界に売る簡単なビジネスです』
しかし、このようにエーアイが順調に強力になっていけばいくほど、そんな危険なものを誰でも使える状態に放置していいのか、という問題が出てきます。
核兵器はもちろんですが、化学兵器や生物兵器につながるものは、情報も含めて、厳しく管理されています。
それでは、エーアイはどうでしょうか。
実際に、アメリカ政府が、アンソロピックの最先端エーアイの提供にストップをかけたことは記憶に新しいですね。
「アンソロピック、米政府指示でミュトス級エーアイ提供停止　日本含む」
仮にエーアイがこのように規制の対象になっていくとするなら、我々のエーアいじゅようの読みは大きく変わります。
こんしゅうはこの問題について考えてみたいと思います。
まずは、読者からの投稿を紹介しましょう。
国家権力が国民全員に各分野の大学教授を超えるレベルのエーアイへのアクセスを許すとは思えず規制でエーアいじゅようが鈍化することを恐れています。
いつもお世話になっています。
私は「エーアイは計算資源を増やせば増やすほど賢くなる」、「こんごもエーアイ向け半導体のじゅようは増え続ける」という第七百四十五号の論にとても違和感を覚えます。
『週刊金融日記 第七百四十五号 なぜエーアイと半導体をめぐる天井なき果てしなき軍拡競争は決して避けられない運命なのか』
技術論としてスケーリング則は間違いないのでしょうが、過去幾度となく行われてきたように、権力者の思惑や都合による「規制」によって流れが捻じ曲げられてしまうのではないでしょうか。
こんご、すでに間違いなく最先端エーアイは核兵器やハイテク軍事技術と同じ扱いを受けるようになり、一般企業や個人ユーザーには性能を抑えた廉価版のようなものしか提供されなくなりますよね。
最先端モデルを利用できる主体が限定されれば、じゅようは国家やいちぶの大企業だけに集中するので、やがてメモリ不足も落ち着いてくるのではないでしょうか。
エーアイが今以上にオープンソース化して進化が止まらないとしても、次はメモリ製造や利用内容に規制をかけることも考えられます。
その場合は供給過剰ではなく、工場建設などの投資に対するリスクの顕在化でしょうか。
私も流れに乗って若干ですが投資してる身ですし、「メモリが爆売れして株価が上がって超ハッピー」という楽しいストーリーも嫌いではないのですが、歴史の中で過去に権力者たちが何をしてきたかを考えると、およそ80億人のポケットの中に各分野のプロフェッサーレベルの知能が備わっている状況を許容できるとは思えないのです。
それでも進化自体は止められないと思いますが、アンダーグラウンド化したりして、なんだかんだ想定よりずっと鈍化するのではないかと。
このように、アメリカ政府が、アメリカに敵対的な個人や組織、国家に、サイバー攻撃でも兵器開発でも極めて有用なエーアイを使われたくない、と考えるのは、ごく自然なことです。
我々はアメリカのエーアイ企業やアメリカ政府に関することは報道でよく目にしますし、エーアイブームにおける株式投資の主役たちもアメリカ企業なので、アメリカのことばかりに目がいきがちです。
しかし、ここで中国政府が、このエーアイ競争をどう見ているのかを確認しておく必要があります。
アメリカが最先端エーアイを国家管理下に置こうとすればするほど、その空白を埋めにくるのが中国だからです。
ひとことで言えば、アメリカが「エーアイを囲い込む」なら、中国は「エーアイをばら撒く」戦略を取っています。
アメリカ政府がアンソロピックの最先端エーアイを止めてから、ちょうど１ヶ月後の７月16日、上海で [EN]「世界AI協力機構（World Artificial Intelligence Cooperation Organization：WAICO）」の設立協定の署名式が開かれました。
[/EN] 王毅外相が中国政府を代表して署名し、ロシア、ブラジル、インドネシア、パキスタン、南アフリカなど29ヶ国が創設加盟国となりました。
本部は上海です。
国連のグテーレス事務総長も出席しました。
１年前の世界エーアイ大会で李強首相が提唱した構想を、たった１年で国際機関にしてしまったわけです。
加盟国はアジア12ヶ国、アフリカ10ヶ国で、ジーセブンは一国も入っておらず、日本も入っていません。
要するに、グローバルサウスを中国のエーアイ経済圏に取り込む「エーアイ版一帯一路」です。
「中国主導の『世界ＡＩ協力機構』発足、ロシアなど29カ国が署名」
[EN]翌17日には世界AI大会（World Artificial Intelligence Conference：WAIC）が開幕し、[/EN] しゅうきんぺいが国家主席として初めて出席して基調演説を行いました。
中国の国家主席がエーアイの展示会に来て演説すること自体、中国政府がエーアイをどれだけ重視しているかを示しています。
演説では、オープンソースエーアイという「またとない歴史的な機会」を各国はつかむべきだと呼びかけ、「エーアイ分野で国家安全保障の概念を過度に拡大し、自国の安全を他国の安全より優先させる行為には共に反対すべきだ」と述べました。
名指しこそしていませんが、アメリカ政府への当てつけです。
さらに、途上国に５年間で5000人分のエーアイ研修枠を提供し、アセアン、アフリカ連合、ブリックスなどに国際エーアイ応用協力センターを整備すると表明しました。
「エーアイの発展は特定の国だけによる独奏であってはならず、世界的な協力による交響曲でなければならない」というのが決め台詞でした。
「しゅうきんぺい主席、世界エーアイ大会開会式で基調演説」
このオープンソース路線は口先だけではありません。
ディープシークやムーンショット エーアイのキミを はじめ、中国勢のフロンティアモデルは軒並みウエイトを公開しています。
世界中の開発者がエーアイモデルを呼び出すのに使うオープンラウターでは、７月時点で上位エンドポイントのトークン処理量の約８割を中国系モデルが占めました。
アメリカのフロンティアモデルが値上げされ、最上位モデルが政府命令で止められている間に、その隙間を中国のオープンウエイトモデルが埋めたのです。
「中国エーアイモデルがオープンラウタートップ10を席巻、米国はアンソロピックのみ生き残り」
ここで、そもそも中国はなぜオープンウエイトなのか、という問いを考えておく必要があります。
しゅうきんぺいは「人類共通の財産」「交響曲」と美しいことを言っていますが、これは慈善事業というわけではありません。
２位の国が取りうる、合理的なビジネス戦略でもあるのです。
理由は３つあります。
第一に、中国は自前で世界中にトークンを売るための強大なエーアイデータセンターを作れません。
アメリカとその同盟国による半導体輸出規制で、エヌビディアの最先端ジーピーユーは手に入らず、イーユーブイ露光装置も止められているので、半導体製造も西側の最先端から数世代遅れています。
代わりにファーウェイのアッセンドが猛追しており、３月に商用出荷が始まった最新のアッセンド950ピーアールは、ことし75万個を出荷する計画です。
しかし、それでもエヌビディアのブラックウェルやルービンとは世代が違いますし、そもそもエイチビーエムも国産化の途上です。
アメリカのハイパースケーラーが年間１兆ドルを投じて建てているようなデータセンターを、中国が同じきぼで建てることは、物理的に不可能なのです。
だとすれば、自社のサーバーで全世界にサービスを提供するのではなく、ウエイトを公開して、アメリカのデータセンターで稼働させたり、ユーザー各自の計算資源で動かしてもらったりするしかありません。
第二に、後追いは、先頭を走るよりも圧倒的に安上がりです。
フロンティアを走る企業は、どの技術的方向が成功するか分からない中で、無数の試行錯誤に莫大な計算資源を投入しています。
２位以下は、その答え合わせを見てから、成功した方向だけを追いかければいい。
研究開発における失敗のコストは、全部１位持ちなのです。
ディープシークの学習費用の安さが世界を驚かせてきたのは、彼らが天才だからというだけでなく、この後発の利益を最大限に使っているからです。
限られた計算資源で戦う中国にとって、フロンティアの開拓競争には参加せず、開拓された道を高速で舗装する、というのは理にかなっています。
第三に、フロンティアでないモデルは、トークンを高く売れません。
アンソロピックのクロードファーベルの料金は出力100万トークン当たり50ドルですが、ディープシークのブイフォープロはピーク時ですら４ドル程度です。
性能で１位に届かないなら価格で勝負するしかなく、価格で勝負するなら、いっそウエイトを公開して世界中の開発者に無料で試してもらい、エコシステムを取りにいくのが最も効率的です。
ところが、面白いことに、ウエイトを公開しても、中国のエーアイ企業はエーピーアイでしっかり稼いでいます。
ザ・インフォメーションの報道によれば、ディープシークのことし1月から7月の売上は4.75億元で、2025年通年の約10倍です。
しかも、エーピーアイ事業の粗利率は80パーセント以上です。
ウエイトを誰でもダウンロードできるのに、なぜ本家のエーピーアイに客が集まるのか。
それは、モデルを訓練した会社が、そのモデルを最も安く効率的に動かすノウハウを持っているからです。
ディープシークは推論インフラの最適化によって、他社より少ないチップで同じモデルを動かしています。
レシピを公開しても、一番うまく料理できるのはそれを考案したシェフなのです。
実際、ディープシークは需要増でインフラ費用がかさんだとして８月にエーピーアイ料金を大幅に値上げし、それでも客は離れていません。
ことし1月から7月のエーアイインフラ投資は110億元と、前年の約10倍です。
ディープシークは5000億元の評価額で新たに500億元を調達し、らいねんの上海上場に向けて投資銀行を雇ったと報じられています。
「ディープシーク売上10倍、7ヶ月売上4.75億元、エーピーアイ粗利82.9パーセント」
「中国ディープシーク、利用料最大12倍値上げ 需要拡大でインフラ費用転嫁」
つまり、中国のオープンウエイト戦略は、「最先端の開拓は１位にやらせて、安く追いつき、ばら撒いてエコシステムを取り、運用ノウハウで稼ぐ」という、２位の国の最適戦略なのです。
そして、これは中国政府にとっても好都合です。
中国のモデルが世界中のデータセンターで動けば動くほど、中国のエーアイ経済圏は広がり、ワイコのようなグローバルサウスの囲い込みが進みます。
しゅうきんぺいの「交響曲」は、２位の合理性を美しい言葉で包んだものでもあるのです。
そして、肝心の「後追い」のスピードが、恐ろしく速くなっています。
ムーンショット エーアイが７月16日、つまりワイク開幕の前日にぶつけてきたキミ ケースリーは衝撃的でした。
2.8兆パラメータと、公開されたオープンウエイトモデルとしては史上最大で、性能を測る [EN]Artificial AnalysisのIntelligence Indexでは57を記録しました。
[/EN] これは世界のトップ２であるクロードファーベルとジーピーティーフォイントシックスソルに次ぐ、堂々の世界３位です。
しかも、開発者がブラインドで評価する [EN]Arena[/EN] のフロントエンドコーディング部門では、クロードファーベルとジーピーティーフォイントシックスソルを抑えて首位に立ちました。
クローズドの最上位モデルと殴り合える性能のモデルのウエイトが、７月27日にそのままハギングフェイスで公開されたのです。
イーロン・マスクは、中国エーアイはベンチマーク上では2026年中にアメリカの最先端に追いつき、実用性も含めて追いつくのは2027年１月から３月だろうと予測しています。
バイトダンスも、ケースリーの３倍以上となる最大10兆パラメータの巨大モデルの開発に乗り出したとエフティーが報じました。
アメリカ政府がサイバー攻撃能力を理由に最上位モデルを囲い込んでも、その数ヶ月後ろを、ウエイト公開前提の中国勢が猛スピードで追いかけてくる。
これが現在の構図です。
「中国のムーンショットエーアイが『キミ ケースリー』発表、高性能に衝撃広がる」
「ティックトックのバイトダンス、『ミュトス』匹敵の大規模エーアイ開発へ エフティー報道」
さて、ここからが本題です。
読者の方は、権力者たちが80億人のポケットに大学教授レベルの知能が入ることを許容するはずがない、だから規制でエーアイの進化は鈍化する、と心配されています。
この心配は、核兵器や化学兵器のアナロジーで考えると、もっともに聞こえます。
しかし、エーアイと核兵器には決定的な違いがあります。
核兵器を作るには、ウランを掘って、遠心分離機を何千台も並べて濃縮して、精密な起爆装置を作らなければなりません。
物理的なモノが必要で、モノは国境で止められます。
アイエーイーエーが査察に来て、遠心分離機の数を数えることができます。
放射性物質が漏れればすぐに検知されます。
化学兵器の原料も同じで、工場と物流が必要です。
ところが、エーアイモデルの本体は、ただの巨大なデータファイルです。
2.8兆パラメータのキミ ケースリーですら、その実体は数テラバイトのファイルにすぎず、ハギングフェイスからダウンロードでき、ハードディスクに入れて持ち運べます。
ひとたび公開されたファイルは、世界中に無限にコピーされ、二度と回収できません。
そして、見方によっては、各分野の大学教授を超える知能を持つキミ ケースリーはすでに無料で世界中にばら撒かれました。
これはインターネットの歴史でなんども見てきたことです。
インターネットのポルノは、どの国の政府がどれだけ規制しても、止まったためしがありません。
海賊版の音楽や映画もそうです。
レコード会社はナップスターを潰しましたが、ファイル共有は形を変えて生き残り、結局、音楽業界のほうがスポティファイというビジネスモデルに適応しました。
ビットコインも同じです。
中国政府は取引所を閉鎖し、マイニングを全面禁止しましたが、マイナーはカザフスタンやアメリカに引っ越しただけで、ビットコインのネットワークは１秒も止まりませんでした。
オープンウエイトのエーアイは、これらと全く同じ性質を持っています。
政府が止められるのは、自国の企業が自国のサーバーから提供するサービスだけです。
ファイルがコピーされていくことは止められません。
しかも、エーアイの場合はもうひとつ重要なことがあります。
作る側がひとつではない、ということです。
アメリカ政府がアンソロピックを止めても、オープンエーアイがいます。
アメリカが両方止めても、中国のディープシークやムーンショット エーアイは止まりません。
逆に中国が自国のエーアイ企業を止めれば、アメリカ勢が突き放すだけです。
規制で自国のエーアイ開発にブレーキをかけることは、相手にエーアイ覇権を献上することを意味します。
思い出してください。
６月のアンソロピックの提供停止騒動は、わずか２週間で解除され、今ではもう誰も話題にしていません。
アンソロピックは政府に対して「限定的なジェイルブレイクの可能性が見つかっただけで数億人が使う商用モデルを回収すべきなら、全てのフロンティアモデルの展開が止まる」と反論しましたが、アメリカ政府が折れた本当の理由は、その間にも中国のオープンウエイトモデルが世界中にダウンロードされ続けていたからでしょう。
しかも、アンソロピックが止められている最中の６月26日、本丸のオープンエーアイは、政府に事前共有した上で新モデルジーピーティーフォイントシックスの限定プレビューを開始し、７月９日には一般公開しました。
最上位のソルは、ファーベルと同水準の性能をほぼ半額で提供していますし、いくつかの分野ではファーベルを上回っています。
つまり、政府の規制がやったことは、アンソロピックの独走を数週間止めて、その間にライバルを追いつかせただけでした。
規制は、エーアイの進化を止めるのではなく、エーアイの進化がどこで、誰によって起きるかを変えるだけなのです。
「オープンエーアイ『ジーピーティーフォイントシックス』一般公開 最上位モデルは『コスト半分で一部ファーベル超え』うたう」
そして、僕は、これは人類にとって悪いことではないと思っています。
ナイジェリアの学生にも、インドネシアの農家にも、日本のサラリーマンにも、月に数千円で各分野の大学教授レベル以上の知識や演繹能力が手に入るのです。
人類の歴史上、知能がこれほど平等に分配された時代はありません。
これは、とてつもなく良い世界です。
印刷技術が生まれたとき、教会と王権は民衆が聖書を読むことを恐れましたが、結果として起きたのは宗教改革と科学革命でした。
しゅうきんぺいがワイクの演説で、エーアイへのアクセスの格差は「新たな歴史的不公正」になると言ったのは、もちろんグローバルサウスを取り込むための政治的なレトリックです。
しかし、それは正しいのです。
もちろん、サイバー攻撃に使える最先端エーアイが世界中の犯罪者やテロリストの手に渡れば、攻撃は激増するでしょう。
しかし、攻撃側がエーアイを持つなら、防御側もエーアイを持ちます。
すでに日立はミュトスを使って、数週間かかっていたサイバー対策の検証作業を数時間に短縮したと報道されました。
中国勢も、オープンウエイトの新モデルを公開する前に、セキュリティチームと組んで実在のソフトウエアから数千件の脆弱性を見つけて報告する、という防御側の実績づくりを始めています。
ソフトウエアの脆弱性は、発見される前から存在しているのですから、エーアイが片っ端から見つけて塞いでいく世界は、放置するよりも安全かもしれません。
そして、塞がれたそばから別のエーアイが新たな穴を探していくでしょう。
つまり、ここでも果てしなき軍拡競争が始まるのです。
「日立、ミュトス活用でサイバー対策の検証作業軽減　数週間を数時間に」
ここまで考えると、規制がエーアいじゅようを鈍化させる、というシナリオのどこに穴があるかが見えてきます。
読者の方の心配が正しいとすれば、それは米中の両政府が足並みをそろえて最先端エーアイを国家管理下に置き、一般企業や個人には性能を抑えた廉価版しか提供しない、という世界です。
たしかに、そうなれば総じゅようは減ります。
アンダーグラウンドで使われ続けるとしても、それで年間１兆ドル以上のせつびとうしが正当化されるはずがありません。
しかし、問題は、その世界が実現するかどうかです。
そして、その答えは、決して実現しない、ということです。
米中のどちらかが自国のエーアイにブレーキをかければ、相手がその分だけ先に進みます。
核兵器なら、米ソは核不拡散条約で「お互いに広めない」と合意できました。
核は国境で止められるので、相手が合意を守っているかどうかをアイエーイーエーが検証できたからです。
エーアイにはそれがありません。
相手がひそかにかいはつを続けているかどうかを検証する手段がない以上、米中がエーアイの開発競争を止める、という合意は成立しないのです。
それでは、米中の合意がなくても、それぞれの政府が国内で囲い込む、つまり「民間には廉価版、最先端は国家だけ」という形ならどうでしょうか。
実は、これは過去に一度試されて、完敗しています。
暗号技術です。
冷戦時代から1990年代まで、アメリカ政府は強力な暗号をミサイルや戦車と同じ「軍需品」に指定して輸出を禁止し、国民が政府に解読できない暗号を使うことを阻止しようとしました。
実際に、ネットスケープのブラウザには、国内版には128ビットの強い暗号、輸出版には40ビットに弱めた暗号が積まれていました。
まさに「自国には最先端、外国には廉価版」です。
しかし、この規制は次々と突破されます。
暗号ソフトピージーピーの作者フィル・ジマーマンは、ソフトの輸出は禁止できても書籍の輸出は言論の自由で禁止できないことを逆手に取り、ソースコードを印刷した6000ページの本を堂々と輸出し、海外のボランティアがそれをスキャンして国際版ピージーピーを作りました。
政府が通信を傍受できるバックドア付き暗号チップを普及させるクリントン政権の構想も、猛反発で廃案になりました。
そして、ネット通販の普及で強い暗号への商業じゅようが爆発すると、アメリカ政府は2000年までに規制を事実上撤廃したのです。
いま、あなたのスマホには、当時の軍用より強力な暗号が入っています。
コピーのコストがゼロで、商業じゅようが巨大で、作れる人間が世界中にいる技術は、国家に囲い込めないのです。
インターネットのポルノを、どの国の政府も止められなかったのと同じ理屈です。
「暗号化ソフトのソースコードを6000ページもの本12冊にして合法的に輸出した壮大なプロジェクト」
しかもエーアイの場合、囲い込みは暗号よりもさらに難しいのです。
きょうの最先端は、数ヶ月後の廉価版だからです。
実際、ファーベルの独走は１ヶ月でオープンエーアイに半額で追いつかれ、その数ヶ月後ろを、ウエイトを公開する中国勢が走っています。
政府が最先端を囲い込んでも、手に入るのはせいぜい数ヶ月のリードで、その間にも「廉価版」の性能はきのうの最先端に追いついていきます。
そして、囲い込んだところで、じゅようは減りません。
第一に、最先端を独占した国家と大企業こそが、最も金を持っていて、最も大量の計算資源を買う主体だからです。
第二に、アメリカ政府は、最先端エーアイを金庫にしまい込んだわけではないからです。
日経が「米政府、ミュトスを外交カード化 中国と競う陣営づくりの代償」と報じたように、アメリカは最先端エーアイへのアクセスを、同盟国を自陣営につなぎとめるための手土産として使い始めています。
中国のワイコに対抗して仲間を増やすには、配るしかないのです。
そして第三に、その囲いの外側にいる国や企業は、中国が公開したウエイトを自分のデータセンターで動かすので、結局、自分でジーピーユーとメモリを買います。
つまり、アメリカの陣営に入ればアメリカのエーアイを使うために、入らなければ中国のエーアイを動かすために、どのみち世界中の誰もが、ジーピーユーとメモリを買い続けるのです。
「米政府、ミュトスを外交カード化　中国と競う陣営づくりの代償」
というわけで、せんしゅうの結論は変わりません。
エーアイと半導体をめぐる天井なき軍拡競争は、止められません。
アメリカが止めれば中国が進み、中国が止めればアメリカが進む。
政府が囲い込めば囲い込むほど、その外側でオープンウエイトが広がる。
ウエイトはただのファイルで、ファイルは国境を越え、ダウンロードされたファイルは二度と回収できません。
核兵器と違って、エーアイには遠心分離機を数えに来るアイエーイーエーは存在しないし、そもそも数えるべき遠心分離機がないのです。
パンドラの箱は、すでに開いてしまいました。
そして、ギリシャ神話のパンドラの箱からさいごに出てきたのは「希望」でした。
80億人のポケットに全ての分野の大学教授が入っている世界は、そんなに悪い世界ではないはずです。
我々個人投資家がやるべきことは、国家権力がエーアイを止めてくれることを願うことでも、恐れることでもなく、止まらない軍拡競争の武器商人、つまり、ジーピーユーとメモリを作っている会社の株を、淡々と持ち続けることです。
２．こんしゅうのマーケット
2026年8月21日から2026年8月28日の週間パフォーマンス
[EN]TOPIX:      4146.71, +2.0% (1w), +21.0% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]Nikkei225: 66405.56, +0.6% (1w), +31.1% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]S&P500:     7711.76, +0.5% (1w), +12.7% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]USD/JPY:     160.04, +0.7% (1w),  +2.3% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]EUR/JPY:     185.43, -0.1% (1w),  +0.9% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]Oil(WTI Fut): 83.40, -4.2% (1w), +45.2% (YTD)[/EN]
「アンソロピック史上初2兆ドルアイピーオーへ、エーアイに殺されるはずのサース株復活、エヌビディア好決算でも売られるメモリ株」
金融日記 ウィークリー 2026年8月21日から2026年8月28日
せんしゅう、８月21日から28日のかぶしきしじょうは、指数こそ小動きだったが、セクターローテーションが起きました。
トピックスは週間で2.0パーセント、日経平均は0.6パーセント、エスアンドピー500は0.5パーセント上昇しました。
一方、エーアイ半導体株はエヌビディア、プラス1.3パーセントを除けば、ブロードコムが、マイナス6.2パーセント、エーエムディーが、マイナス1.6パーセント、マイクロンが、マイナス3.5パーセント、エーエスエムエルが、マイナス3.8パーセントなどが軟調で、日本でもキオクシアが、マイナス11.8パーセントが大きく売られました。
ドル円は160円台へ再び円安が進み、ダブリューティーアイ原油先物は4.2パーセント下落しました。
週末にはウォーシュエフアールビー議長のタカ派的な発言を受けて米短期金利とドルが上昇し、株価の上値を抑えました。
代わりに買われたのが、「エーアイに殺される」と言われてきたサース株です。
セールスフォースは好決算を受けて週間22.4パーセント高となり、クラウドストライクも決算後に約21パーセント、オクタは約29パーセント急騰しました。
セールスフォースは売上が11パーセント増えただけでなく、将来売上の先行指標である [EN]cRPO（Current Remaining Performance Obligation：現在の残存履行義務）[/EN] が14パーセント増となりました。
生成エーアイが既存サースを破壊するという単純なストーリーとは逆に、顧客データ、業務フロー、販売網を握っている既存サース企業は、エーアイを新たな高付加価値商品として売り始めています。
そして、メモリ株を中心に株価は冴えないが、エーアイ半導体のファンダメンタルズはまったく崩れていません。
エヌビディアのキューツー売上高は前年同期比106パーセント増の962億ドル、粗利益率も75パーセントを維持しました。
さらに2028年1月期の売上高が約70パーセント成長するとの見通しを示しました。
ジェンスン・ファン シーイーオーはじゅようがなお加速しており、むしろメモリを中心とする部材不足できょうきゅうが制約されていると説明しています。
エスケイハイニックスのノ・ジョンウォン シーイーオーも、メモリ半導体の供給不足は2030年まで続き、じゅようが減ずる兆候は見えないと述べました。
エヌビディア自身が「じゅようが強すぎてきょうきゅうできない」と言い、エスケイハイニックスも2030年まで供給不足だと言い、マイクロソフト、アルファベット、メタ、アマゾンは揃ってエーアイせつびとうしを増額しています。
それでもマイクロンやキオクシアが売られているのだから、しじょうはよほどメモリサイクルのピークアウトを信じたいらしい。
筆者には、株価と実体経済のどちらを信じるべきかはかなり明白に思えます。
エーアイ半導体、とりわけメモリ株への強気の見方はまったく変わりません。
そして、オープンエーアイと並びエーアイ革命の本丸がいよいよ上場です。
クロードを開発するアンソロピックが、早ければ今秋にもじょうじょうし、２兆ドル以上の時価総額で1000億ドルきぼを調達する史上最大のアイピーオーを準備しています。
アンソロピックの年率換算売上高はさくねん末の約90億ドルから７月末には650億ドル超へ膨らみ、投資家は年末には1000億円から1200億ドルに達すると見込んでいます。
もちろん、これは直近の売上を年率換算したランレートであり実績ではないが、それでも異常な成長速度です。
1000億ドルもの新株をしじょうが吸収するには、当然どこかから現金を持ってこなければなりません。
アンソロピックという新しい「純粋エーアイ銘柄」を買うため、これまで大きく上昇してきたエーアイ半導体株をいったん売って現金化する投資家が出るのは自然です。
足元のメモリ株の弱さには、ファンダメンタルズではなく、この種の巨大アイピーオーを前にしたポートフォリオの組み替えも混じっているのかもしれません。
こんしゅうのマクロ経済指標は、４日の米８月雇用統計に注目が集まります。
ロイターズ調査では雇用者数は約５万8000人増、失業率4.1パーセントが予想されています。
弱すぎれば景気後退懸念、強すぎればウォーシュエフアールビーの追加利上げ観測を高めることになります。
また、２日にはブロードコムのキュースリー決算があり、エヌビディアに続いてエーアイ向けカスタムエーエスアイシーとネットワーク需要の強さを確認することになるでしょう。
１日にはエーアイサーバー企業となったデルの決算もあります。
エーアいじゅようが依然として極めて強いことが確認されることになるでしょう。
「エフアールビー議長のタカ派姿勢、ジャクソンホール会議で鮮明に」
「エーアイに殺されるはずのサース株が急騰！
シーアールエム・オクタ・シーアールダブリューディーの好決算は『終焉論』を覆すのか？
」
「米セールスフォース、通期見通し上方修正　アンソロピックと提携拡大」
「ハイニックスシーイーオー『2030年まで半導体供給不足は続く…景気後退の兆候はない』」
「アンソロピック、史上初２兆ドルアイピーオー最終段階　ミュトス生んだエーアイ開発力」
エックスサブスク、３ドルパーつきなんですが、主要企業の決算分析や、エーアイバブルの現在位置について筆者とエーアイの対談記事が読めます。
購読希望の方は、アップルにピンハネされるアイフォンアプリからではなく、スマホやピーシーのブラウザからエックスのサイトを開き、そこで直接サブスクリプションを登録して、ついでに、イーロン・マスク氏の宇宙開発も同時に応援してください。
８月31日（月）
日7月鉱工業生産指数
日7月商業動態統計
日7月住宅着工統計
中国8月製造業ピーエムアイ
ジーセブン・ジーツウェンティ財務大臣・中央銀行総裁会議（米ノースカロライナ州、８月31日から９月１日）
休場：英（サマー・バンクホリデー）
9月1日（火）
日4月から6月期法人企業統計
日8月新車販売台数
日8月軽自動車新車販売台数
日10年国債入札
米8月アイエスエム製造業景気指数
米7月雇用動態調査、ジェイオーエルティーエス求人件数
米7月建設支出
中国8月レーティングドッグ製造業購買担当者景気指数、ピーエムアイ
決算：デル、他
9月2日（水）
日8月マネタリーベース
米8月エーディーピー雇用統計
米7月製造業受注
米ベージュブック
決算：ブロードコム、他
9月3日（木）
日30年国債入札
米7月貿易収支
米8月アイエスエム非製造業指数
9月4日（金）
日7月家計調査
米8月雇用統計
９月５日（土）
９月６日（日）
３．ブログでは言えないお店
週末の丸の内でフレンチで居酒屋風に楽しみました
東京は和食よりフレンチとイタリアンだ、と常々僕は思っているのですが、それを実践するべく、さっそく週末の丸の内のフレンチに行ってきました。
丸の内みたいなオフィス街は週末は空いていていいんですよね。
当日に丸の内でお店を探していたのですが、電話したら席があるということで、行ってきました。
場所は、丸の内仲通り沿いにある「二重橋スクエア」の１階、ル ブール ノワゼット トウキョウです。
ここはパリにある人気レストランの分店です。
週刊金融日記第七百四十六号をお届けします。
東京店で、ホテル・リッツ・パリなどで腕を磨いたティエリー・ブランキ氏という有名シェフが手掛けるお店の系譜です。
確かな技術の料理をカジュアルに提供する「ネオ・ビストロ」というコンセプトらしいです。
まあ、客の立場からすると、その有名シェフが丸の内の厨房で実際に料理しているわけじゃないし、名前代としてのフランチャイズ料とかも払ってるんだろうから、これは推測で僕は知りませんけどね、ちょっとアレではあるんですけどね。
丸の内の真ん中で、ガラス張りで開放感もあって、外から見ると良い雰囲気ですね。
さて、このお店は、席のシステムがちょっとわかりにくいので注意してください。
店内が「レストラン」と「バル」の二つのエリアに分かれているんですが、奥のレストラン側は「コース料理のみ」です。
今回のように、好きなものをアラカルトでバンバン注文したいなら、手前側の「バル」エリアを選ぶ必要があり、こっちの方がよりカジュアルです。
デートでしっかりフレンチのコースを食べたい時は奥のレストラン、仲間とワインを飲みながらアラカルトでワイワイやりたい時は手前のバル、という風な使い分けでしょう。
まあ、実際にワインと料理がどんなもんかは、写真を見てください。
スパークリングワインも一本五千円ぐらいで、香港と比べると、お値打ち、と感じてしまいます。
たしか北海道かどっかのビーフ、自家製ソーセージ、そして、また、おいしい赤ワインをボトル五千円で追加。
そんで、居酒屋みたいにみんなで食べるために、取り皿を持ってきてもらいました。
なんか、お店の人も、こういう取り皿に慣れている様子で、良い意味でカジュアルでいいですね。
鮎のコンフィはマジでおいしかった。
頭も全部食べられます。
そして、白ワインをボトルで追加です。
これも安くなっていて五千円ぐらいです。
ブイヤベースもおいしい。
ブイヤベースの残ったスープでリゾットです。
たしか追加料金千円とかなんか。
鴨を追加、牛肉の赤ワイン煮込み追加、穴子のフリット追加です。
おいしいワインをめちゃ飲んで、フレンチもたくさん食べて、さあ、おいくら万円なんでしょう。
全部の料理を載せていませんし、デザートまで頼んだんですが、スパークリングをボトル一本、赤ワインをボトル一本、白ワインをボトル一本で、こんだけたくさん食べて、五人で五万円ちょっとでした。
週末だからなのか、お客さんも店員も、割とファミレスの延長的なカジュアルな雰囲気で、取り皿とか手慣れたもんで、居酒屋的に楽しめましたわ。
まあ、香港でちょっといいカジュアルなフレンチだと一人二万円ぐらいですから、一人一万円でこんだけ飲んで食べられる東京のフレンチは半額なんで、やはりコスパが良いですね。
ル ブール ノワゼット、東京都千代田区丸の内三丁目二番三号丸の内二重橋ビル二重橋スクエア一階。
電話番号はゼロ三ハイフンシックスニセブファイブハイフンシックスゼロゼロセブンです。
続いて、ふじさわかずきの身もフタもない人生相談についてです。
SKハイニックス株を買いたいのですが、エーディーアールで買うと為替や取引手数料がかかる上に三十パーセントもプレミアムがついている件と所長がコスピを買った理由についてというご質問をいただいています。
いつもお世話になっております。
韓国しじょうのSKハイニックス株の購入を検討しているのですが、安いところでも取引・為替手数料諸々込みで売買往復で五・七パーセント程度取られてしまうようで尻込みしております。
一方、米国上場のエーディーアールのスケーエイチワイはというと、プレミアムがプラス三十パーセント位で推移しております。
私は長期で保有するつもりなのですが、所長的に「買ってもいいかな」となるプレミアムはどれくらいの数字の時になりますでしょうか。
はたまた、SKハイが二割以上入ったディーラムイーティーエフも魅力的なのですが、単純にピーイー比が低めのSKハイにフルで賭けたい気持ちがあります。
リスクも許容できます。
雑ですが、両方ともかぶしゅうえきりつは十倍ぐらいと仮定すると、SKハイの方がディーラムイーティーエフより二十パーセント～三十パーセントぐらい上昇余地があるのかなと思ったのですが、韓国株へのエントリー費用が五・七パーセントということで、素人的にリスクを感じてしまっております。
投資は自己責任ではありますが、何かアドバイス等いただけますと幸いです。
余談なのですが、所長がディーラムイーティーエフではなくコスピ指数を買っている理由についてお伺いできたら嬉しいです。
盛りだくさんで申し訳ありませんがよろしくお願いいたします。
ふじさわかずきの回答です。
中国企業は、香港と上海・深セン（しんせん）に両方ともじょうじょうしていることが多く、経済的には同じ議決権、利益の分配を受け取る権利を持っている香港の上場株、H株と中国の上場株、A株で、だいぶ株価が違って、さいしょは不思議でした。
僕は証券会社で裁定取引にも関わっていましたから、ふつうに考えて、そんなんすぐ裁定されるんちゃうか、と。
それでいろいろ調べたんですけど、H株とA株を交換する手段がないんですよ。
H株はずっとH株で香港でしか売買できず、A株も同じです。
だから、ファンダメンタル的には同じ価値でも、香港で香港ドルでしか売買できないH株と、中国内で人民元でしか売買できないA株では、株価が違ってきても、まあ、不思議じゃないんですよね。
それで、西側投資家は中国ディスカウントをしますから、H株とA株だと、通常はH株の方が一割以上安いですね。
しかし、シーエーティーエル、つまり世界最大のバッテリーメーカーみたいに、西側投資家も注目していて、深センはメインボード、主板じゃなくて、認可を受けた機関投資家しか売買できないチャイネクストという創業板なんで、中国外の個人は買えませんから、H株の方にだいぶプレミアムがついちゃっていますね。
さて、前置きは長くなりましたが、アメリカにもエーディーアールとしてじょうじょうしたSKハイニックス株ですが、韓国の株とエーディーアールを直接交換する手段がないし、韓国しじょうにアクセスがある証券会社は限られるし、あっても為替とか大変などの同じような理由で、裁定取引が起こらずに、本場の韓国より、アメリカの方がだいぶプレミアムがついちゃっています。
じゃあ、買える手段があるなら、韓国で買ったほうが得なんか、というとそこは何とも言えないところで、アメリカの法規制の下で、アメリカの流動性のあるしじょうで常に米ドルに替えられるエーディーアールというものには適正なプレミアムがあって当然である、という考えもあります。
それで、ディーラムのイーティーエフですが、こっちだと韓国株を直接買っているんで。
実は、トータルリターンスワップというデリバティブをさまざまな理由で使っているんですが、これを説明すると長くなるんで省略します。
結論だけ言うと、個人投資家にとっては悪いもんじゃない、ということです。
だから、エーディーアールのプレミアムが嫌ならディーラム買えばいいんですが、メモリー株全般に分散されているんじゃなくて、SKハイニックスだけを買いたいんや、ということですよね。
じゃあ、プレミアム払って、日本の証券会社ならだいたい買えるエーディーアールを買えばいいんじゃないか、と。
さて、僕がなぜディーラムじゃなくて、コスピなのか、というとですね、これもいろいろな制約の上でのことです。
僕は短中期の株の売買とか先物とかオプションとかは、手数料が安くアメリカしじょうに強い米国のネット証券会社の香港のやつを使っていて、買いっぱなし長期投資は、別の銀行におまけみたいについている証券口座でやっています。
それで、香港に住んで香港法人でいろいろビジネスしているんで、その法人口座もあってですね、ここは余ったお金を、インデックスファンドとかにぶっこんで放置しているんですわ。
それで、税制とか為替手数料とか考えると、香港しじょうに上場されているものが好ましいんですよ。
日本はアメリカの同盟国で租税条約がありますから、アメリカ株の配当とかイーティーエフの分配金とかの源泉徴収が安いんですが、香港居住者だとそんな租税条約がありませんから、マックス税率でして、強欲なアメリカ政府に三十パーセントも取られるんですよ。
それで、香港に上場されているのがコスピのイーティーエフなんで、これを買ったという次第です。
香港の法人口座の金をコスピにぶっこみました。
韓国兄さんたちと同じ船に乗りました。
生命保険を解約して、借金してまで、SKハイニックスに信用全開でつっこむ韓国の同志たちに、僕は心を打たれました。
続いて、メモリ半導体株の低ピーイー比は歴史的なミスプライスなのかの最終回を早く書いてください、というご要望をいただいています。
藤沢先生へのご質問です。
お世話になります、ミッシェルです。
八月も終わります。
お盆にサンディスクが以下の素晴らしい見通しを示したインベスターデーを経て、「エフワイ二十八～三十も売上十パーセント台半ば～後半成長、粗利率は約八十パーセント」と発表しました。
先週に神決算を発表したエヌビディアも、以下の長期的な見通しを示しました。
「二〇二八年一月期も七十パーセント成長する。
需要はそれ以上あるがきょうきゅうの制約がある。
ただし、メモリ価格高騰により粗利率が下がる」
この文脈での「メモリ」とは主にエイチビーエムのことを指すと思いますが、ナンドフラッシュも関わることでしょう。
先週は他にも、スケーエイチハイニックスのシーイーオーが、米国インディアナ州の工場起工式で「メモリ不足は二〇三〇年まで続く」とコメントしました。
ハイニックスシーイーオーは「二〇三〇年まで半導体供給不足は続く。
景気後退の兆候はない」とコメントしています。
にもかかわらず、我らが「特急列車二百八十五エー号」は、高市首相とサンディスクシーイーオーと共に表明した「五兆円投資」が供給過剰のイメージを湧かせてしじょうに嫌気されたのか、グズグズしていますね。
ただし、キオクシアはもともと、エフワイ二〇二六～二十八平均で年間四千七百億円の投資を予定していました。
今回の「五兆円投資」はキオクシア負担分を六割とすると三兆円、投資期間の六年間で割ると年間五千億円なので、「しじょうの様子を見ながら、二十九年以降もこないだ発表したペースで投資していきます」ぐらいのことなんですけどね。
投資額の三分の一の補助金を出すとされる日本政府としては、先日サムスン、スケーエイチハイニックスの両シーイーオーと共に巨大投資を発表した韓国政府を、大いに意識していると感じさせるパフォーマンスでした。
この八月もいろいろありましたが、メモリ株について熱く語り合った二〇二六年の夏を締めくくるべく、「メモリ半導体株、マイクロン、スケーエイチハイニックス、サムスン、キオクシアの低ピーイー比は歴史的なミスプライスなのか、供給編」の以下の伏線を回収する、「最終回」をぜひお願いします。
シーエックスエムティーのアイピーオーは、メモリ株のピーイー比を読むことの難しさを極端な形で見せてくれます。
想定時価総額五千七百九十二億元は、二〇二五年通期の親会社帰属利益十八・七十五億元に対してはピーイー比約三百九倍です。
ところが二〇二六年第一四半期の利益二百四十八億元を機械的に年率換算すれば、ピーイー比は約六倍まで落ちます。
同じ株価が、通期実績ではピーイー比三百倍超、直近四半期の年換算ではピーイー比六倍です。
国家の威信をかけた史上最大のアイピーオーですらこうなのだから、価格と利益が急変するメモリ企業を単年度のピーイー比で評価することが、いかに危ういかが分かるでしょう。
そしてこの問いは、そっくりそのまま本稿の主役たち、ピーイー比四倍で放置されるスケーエイチハイニックスやマイクロンに返ってきます。
その分母のイーピーエスは、はたして「正常利益」なのか。
最終回の伏線として、覚えておいてほしいです。
つまり、この議論の争点は、二〇二八年以降の世界に何があるかだということです。
筆者の見るところ、しじょうがゼロ評価しているのはまさにそこなんです。
世界モデルと合成データが生む「機械が機械のために生む需要」、フィジカルエーアイとその一分野である自律型軍事ドローン、各国が競ってかいはつするソブリンエーアイ、価格に殺されて行列を作っているエッジエーアイの待機需要などです。
二〇二八年以降のきょうきゅうの増加に、これらの新しいじゅようがぶつかったとき、メモリ半導体の価格はそれでも大きく崩れるのでしょうか。
それともこれらの「新たな需要」が二〇二八年以降の供給増をさらに上回るのでしょうか。
来週の最終回で、これを解説します。
歴史的ミスプライスなのか、しじょうが正しいのか。
我々の答えを出そう。
『週刊金融日記第七百四十号メモリ半導体株、マイクロン、スケーエイチハイニックス、サムスン、キオクシアの低ピーイー比は歴史的なミスプライスなのか、供給編』とのことです。
ミッシェルからのご質問に対する、ふじさわかずきの回答です。
まあ、僕の場合、メモリ半導体株は、二〇二八年ぐらいの「答え合わせ」まで持つつもりなんで、いろいろな需給要因や、間違った情報が広まったりして、株価がぐずぐずしていてくれても全く気になりません。
むしろ、臨時でキャッシュが入ったときなんかに、まだ、買えるオプションが残っていた方がいいぐらいですわ。
ということで、エーアイと半導体が、いま世界でいちばん重要なテーマではありますから、総合メルマガとして、グルメやファッションなどの軽い話題も書きつつ、頃合いを見て、最終回を書くので、しばらくお待ちください。
以上で今回の放送を終わります。
またお聞きください。